eu environment ministers have agreed on
the need to green up the eu's economic
governance system the european semester
and europe's 2020 growth strategy for
the coming decade
at their council in luxembourg the
ministers underlined that environment
policies are important to solving the
challenges faced by eu economies
in particular they noted the potential
for green growth and employment that
could be created by encouraging more
resource efficiency
shifting taxes from labor to pollution
could help create more jobs while green
infrastructure could also be developed
and environmentally harmful subsidies
phased out
the ministers also held a public debate
on waste management eu nations produced
a total of 2.5 billion tons of waste in
2011.
if we want to
use resources efficiently and if we want
to have a circular economy then we've
got to produce
less waste
we've got to cut production of waste
too much waste is wasteful to go in a
phrase
of the roughly half a tonne of waste
produced by each eu citizen annually
only around 40 percent is recycled
most of that recycled waste is used as
landfill the rest is usually incinerated
this wastage deprives the european
economy of many important secondary
materials like metals wood glass paper
and plastic